is this video captured from a U.S
fighter jet proof that aliens exist the
Pentagon says no but these former
military men told a congressional
committee they believe it is proof one
former pilot says he's seen it for
himself all four of us because we were
in f-18f so we had pilots and wizard in
the back seat looked down a small saw
white Tic-Tac object with a longitudinal
axis pointing North South and moving
very abruptly over the water like a ping
pong ball there were no rotors no rotor
wash or any sign of visible control
surfaces like wings
[Music]
says no military has the technology to
fly like that but David grush a
whistleblower and Former Intelligence
officer took it even further saying he
was told that for decades the US
government was recovering crashed alien
spacecraft to try and re-engineer the
technology if you believe we have
crashed craft stated earlier do we have
the bodies of the pilots who piloted
this craft
as I've stated publicly already in my
news Nation interview biologics came
with some of these recoveries yeah
were they I guess human or non-human
biologics
non-human and that was the assessment of
people with direct knowledge on the
program I talked to that are currently
still on the program
the Pentagon flatly denies this
allegation but Congress says it wants
answers and is considering a bill that
would force the Biden Administration to
make public everything it knows on what
it calls uaps unidentified aerial
phenomena
another witness says if that happens
look out for talk of a flying Black Cube
10 miles off the coast of Virginia Beach
two F-18 Super Hornets were split by UAP
the object described as a dark gray or a
black Cube inside of a clear sphere came
within 50 feet of the lead aircraft and
was estimated to be 5 to 15 feet in
diameter the mission Commander
terminated the flight immediately and
returned base
our Squadron submitted a safety report
but there was no official acknowledgment
of the incident and no further mechanism
to report the sightings
Congress wants to change that in hopes
of answering the age-old question are we
really alone
Al Jazeera Washington
foreign